humans are corrupt every single
institution on the face of the planet
that is run by humans which is currently
all of them at some degree is corrupt
all of them whether it's doctors
Financial judicial Law and Order the
monetary system it's all completely and
utterly corrupt and to sit here and
believe that any of them are just and
fair I think we've just learned in the
last few years that we can see that even
simple things like keeping people alive
even medicine is completely corrupt from
head to toe all of it is so you have to
understand that and then you have to
look at the chessboard and go okay if
it's all completely and utterly corrupt
and I understand that there are certain
people who get to play the game on cheat
mode
do I want to be able to play the game on
cheat mode if I'm gonna try and be the
best version of myself well yes I could
possibly do that in Nigeria I could play
on cheat mode I could possibly play on
cheat mode in Croatia I could possibly
play on cheat mode here here I have to
stick to the rules if I have to obey the
rules of Chess against a person who can
move their pieces however they want I'm
going to be perpetually crushed for
attorney